RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT THE
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IT
COMPLIES WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROP. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC IN OUR
EMPLOYEES AS WE COMPLY WITH
THESE ORDERS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
IN DEBATE REMOTELY WITH IT IS A
VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM.
REMEMBER WILL BE A TEN BELIEVE
DAY PLEASE MAKE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS. ARE IT PERSONNEL
WILL MUTE AND UNMUTE THE VIDEO
SERVICE WHEN YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
THIS WILL GREATLY EIGHT
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK IT EVERY TIME
YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR QUESTION
YOU USED THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. WHAT'S
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME IN THE BILL
NUMBER TO WHICH YOU ARE
REFERRING. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TWO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A MOMENT.
TODAY'S PARTICIPATE NUMBER. IS
ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO THREE SEVEN
NINE FOUR THREE SEVEN. WHEN WE
MOVED THE PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY INTO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST USE YOUR
DEVICE. YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT IS MADE TO STREAMLINE
THE HEARING PROCESS IN ARC AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS.
AND A FEW TECHNICAL ISSUES AS
WE PROCEED TODAY. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES. CAN
PARTICIPATE AND BE HEARD. OKAY
WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WE WILL BE HEARING BILLS
IN FILE ORDER BEGINNING WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. I WANT TO
REMIND MEMBERS THAT WE BEAT WE
WILL ONLY BE OPENING UP THE
ROLE ONE TIME ONCE A BILL IS
HAS THE NECESSARY VOTES I'LL BE
CLOSING THE ROLE AND NOT
OPENING IT AGAIN. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON BILLS
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. US
SECRETARY COULD WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OUR DAUGHTER YOUR
HERE WELCOME. ALLEN THERE
ARCHULETA. BRADFORD CHIANG.
GALGIANI HELLO. THERE WAS SOME
JONES. NIELSEN PORTANTINO.
RUBIO WIENER. FAMILY HAVE A
QUORUM. THE SECRETARY NOTES A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
GLAZER IN SENATOR BOARD JUST
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FROM THEIR DISTRICT OFFICES
THEY WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE COMMENTS QUESTIONS
AND DEBATE BUT WILL NOT BE
VOTING. WE'LL BEGIN OUR WITH
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR. THOSE ARE
FILE TEMS ONE SB SEVEN NINETY
FOUR FILE ITEM TO SB EIGHT
HUNDRED FILE ITEM FOR SB EIGHT
SIXTY NINE. AND FILE ITEM FIVE
SB NINE EIGHTEEN CAN I HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSECUTIVE. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU- THE
CONSECUTIVE HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER ARCHULETA SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DODD. HI
DONNA HI WILK. WELCOME WELL I
ALLEN ALLEN HI ANGELA ANGELA HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I CHIANG.
CHIANG HI GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL. HILL AYE HUESO. HUESO AYE
JONES. NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE
CORTINA. PORTANTINO I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER THE ONE ON THE
LINE NINA. HI WIENER HI. THAT'S
THIRTEEN CELLS ARE GERMAN
THIRTY YES THERE'S THIRTEEN
EYES THOSE ARE ZERO THAT
MOTION- WELL THOUGH. YES THAT'S
THE. CONCERT CALENDAR PASSES
THANK YOU- WE DO NEED TO BE A
LITTLE BIT LOUDER WHEN YOU- SO
WE CAN HEAR YOUR VOTE VOTES
BEING RECORDED PLEASE THANK YOU.
OKAY NOW LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AUTHOR. CENTER HILL YOU
MAY PRESENT SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU IN MEMBERS SB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE BUILDS UPON MY
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION TO PROMOTE
SAFE EXCAVATION PRACTICES WALL
GREAT STRIDES HAVE BEEN MADE TO
GET WORKERS HOME SAFELY TO
THEIR FAMILIES. DEVASTATING AND
OFTEN PREVENTABLE ACCIDENTS HI
CONTINUE TO OCCUR. IN JULY
TWENTY NINETEEN A SEWER
CONTRACTOR STRUCK A SO CALLED
GAS PIPELINE WHILE WORKING AT A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME. THE
SUBSEQUENT LEAK IGNITED KILLING
A UTILITY WORKER AND INJURING
FIFTEEN OTHERS IT APPEARS THE
CONTRACTOR DID NOT CONSIDER
THEMSELVES AN EXCAVATOR AND
NEVER CALLED EIGHT ONE ONE. THE
CAUSES FOR EXCAVATION ACCIDENTS
ARE VERY. AND MAY ARISE FROM
ANY BREAK IN THE CALL BEFORE
YOU DIG CHAIN BUT THE SOLUTION
IS CRYSTAL CLEAR. BETTER
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN ALL
STAKEHOLDERS CRITICS SAY BOARD
WAS ESTABLISHED TO IMPROVE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE CALL BEFORE
YOU DIG LAW AND TO EVALUATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR APPROVING
SAFETY. THEY ARE PREPARING TO
HOLD THEIR FIRST INVESTIGATION
AND ENFORCEMENT HEARINGS LATER
THIS YEAR. BUT THEY CANNOT DO
THEIR JOB WITHOUT THE PROPER
DATA THE NUMBER OF BEGINS.
WHERE THESE ACCIDENTS ARE
OCCURRING HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
pINDUSTRIES ARE CALLING IN WHICH
INDUSTRIES ARE NOT. SB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE EQUIPS THE DIG SAFE
BOARD WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS
TO PERFORM THEIR STATUTORY
DUTY. SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE ALSO
ENSURES THAT EXCAVATORS HAVE
ACCURATE INFORMATION BEFORE A
SHOVEL FULL OF EARTH IS TURNED
BY REQUIRING ALL NEW SUBSURFACE
INSTALLATIONS B. G. I. S. TAG.
SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE MOVES THE
DIG SAFE BOARD TO THE OFFICE OF
ENERGY AND INFRASTRUCTURE
STRUCTURE SAFETY WHICH BETTER
ALIGNS WITH THEIR MISSION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LAKE THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES
WILL INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY EACH
SIDE WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUCH
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THESE MEASURES. NOW LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS. THIRTY MEMBER
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO OH FOUR
OO THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT SIXTY FIVE.
I'M SEEING NOBODY AND ROOM AS I
MEET ROOM TWENTY FORTY THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF
YOU PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT. SIXTY FIVE WILL
BEGIN. THEY'RE NOT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATE PLEASE- GIVE
ME SO THERE'S NOBODY WAITING
THIS. OF YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES. SO WE'RE NOT DOING THAT
SKEWS ME. CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
THE LINE AGAIN DECISION IF
YOU'RE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM EVERYBODY ON SB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE. BUT MISTER
CHAIRMAN- THIS IS THE ONLY
GARCIA REPRESENTING THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WORST.
ANALYSTS AND- SORRY HOLD ON
SACRAMENTO ON PINE. HE SHOWED
FOUR OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE TEN ZERO AT THAT TIME.
AGAIN TO SHIFT TO SHOW THE POOR
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS THE
ONE AT THE END THERE AT THIS
TIME. SO MODERATE AND WE HAVE.
AN ALLY AND FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLEASE PROCEED TO THATME YES. HELLO THIS IS JANE
TWENTY EIGHT- FROM UNDERGROUND
SERVICE ALERT OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA COMMONLY
KNOWN AS YOU WITH THE NORTH
EIGHT ONE ONE WE ARE THE EIGHT
ONE ONE CALL CENTER THE COVER
THE MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE SUPPORT THAT
NEED EIGHT SIXTY FIVE BECAUSE
WE AGREED THAT THE AGGREGATION
OF DAMAGE DATA IS IMPORTANT
THAT ARE CURRENTLY NOT BEING
COLLECTED RIGHT NOW. AND WE
ALSO AGREE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO TAG. ORDINANCE AND THE GIS
SYSTEM FOR THE FACILITY
OPERATORS TO KEEP TRACK OF
THEIR UNDERGROUND FACILITY.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
THE LINE ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE
SURE WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL IN
SUPPORT- SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
POLICE. YEAH AS A REMINDER IF
YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS WHY NOT BEEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN WHY NOT BEEN PAYROLL
TO SHOW SUPPORT. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HAVING HER FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. SEEING NOBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS. WE WILL MOVE TO ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO
OH FOUR OH WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHT SIXTY SB
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE. SEEING THEIR
NOBODY AND- ROOM TO FOR WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE WILL BEGIN. TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE BEEN THERE AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN TO OPPOSE THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON LOCAL
JULY NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THIS IS THE LEGACY BROOKLYN IN
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE DID SUBMIT A
LETTER OF OPPOSITION. AND THE
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS AND AT
THIS TIME WE DO ON OUR EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO SIT ON THE
HILL AND YOUR STAFF. BY THE
TIME THAT THEY RECORDED US. TO
SHARE WITH THEM MY CONCERNS-
WITH THE BILL'S PROVISIONS AS
IT WERE LAKE AND- LOW LYING
NAKED. OILFIELD AND THAT WE CAN
LOOK FORWARD TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION UP ON RUBIO PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA. MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. HAIR AGAIN TO OPPOSE
THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE
AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND. SORRY AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE OUGHT TO A POLE. THERE'S
NO ONE IN Q. AT THE MOMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE
WILL BRING THIS NOW BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS FOR DISCUSSION. I SEE-
WE HAVE SENATOR GLAZER- ON. THE
PHONE LINE OR THE ZOOM AREAS
SENATOR. I DID THE- MAYBE TAKE
HIM OFF THE MIDDLE WE CAN'T
HEAR YOU. YOU NEED TO ALL RIGHT
HERE NOW YOUR SELF OF NEW. YOU
HEAR ME NOW YES SENATOR WE CAN
HEAR YOU NOW ALL RIGHT THAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR INDULGENCE OF
MEDIA. DISSIPATING REMOTELY. IT
WAS SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES AT
THE START I DON'T KNOW IF TO
CENTER HILL. ADDRESS THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- WHISPER I
SPOKE TO EARLIER. IF HE HAS THE
MY APOLOGIES FOR ASKING HIM TO
GET HIS REACTION TO THAT- BUT
THAT WAS THAT WAS MY QUESTION.
FULLER HILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER YES WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION ON THE-
IDENTIFICATION OF THE
PIPELINE'S UNDERGROUND THAT-
THAT THEY DEAL WITH AND WORK
WITH ON A CONTINUOUS BASIS WITH
IN THEIR OIL FIELDS. AND WE'VE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT AND THAT
LANGUAGE WILL BE- ADOPTED I
DON'T BELIEVE IN GEO BUT AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD THEY WILL BE
INCLUDED. GREAT THANK OU VERY
MUCH SENATOR HELP FOR ****
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. WITH
THAT CENTER HILL WHICH I CLOSE
SO APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORKING
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSIONS
WITH- WISH BUT AND- BEING ABLE
TO COME TO AN ACCOMMODATION
WITH THEM AND- RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR LIVE- CALLING TO THIS
UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCE. WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. MOTION BY
SENATOR WILK COMMITTEE. CAN WE-
THE MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL TO FOLLOW HIM
THREE SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD
BY DOT I WILL. WILK AYE ALLEN
AYE ALLEN AYE ATTILA. ACTUALLY
I AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
CHIANG CHIANG HI GALGIANI
GALGIANI I'D KILL HILL I WANT
SOME. HUESO AYE JONES. NIELSEN
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO. REALLY
ARE YOU KNOW. WE ALRIGHT THAT'S
THIRTEEN ZERO TURN. THE BILL IS
OUT OF THIRTY NINE ZERO DOES WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FIGHT A FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX BY SENATOR
WELL. I UNDERSTAND THAT CENTER
JOE TO SEE HERE. IT'S COMING IN
RIGHT NOW CENTER JONES WILL BE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
MORALE. SENATOR JONES. CENTER
JUDGE YOU MAY PRESENT SB ELEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT. ONE ARM AND ALL
ONE ARMED BANDIT. HOPE THAT'S
NOT THE BILL'S ABOUT. MEMBERS
APOLOGIZE FOR MY TARDINESS. AS
RUNNING DOWN CARCASS LUNCH. AND
I HAVE THE GREAT PLEASURE AND
HONOR OF- PRESENTING SB ELEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR MORALE.
AND I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED ON PAGE FOUR- ACTUALLY
SEND RURAL EXCEPT IN MINUTES-
OUTLINED ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THINK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL. THIS BILL IS
INCREDIBLY TIMELY AS CALIFORNIA
HAS SEEN A SERIES OF
SIGNIFICANTLY DAMAGING AND
COSTLY DISASTERS IN RECENT
HISTORY. INCLUDING THE CURRENT
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SB
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT SERVES. THE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST AFFECTED BY
THESE TRIP TRAGEDIES THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES. ANY STATE AGENCY
THAT ISSUES A BUSINESS OR
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS TO EXPEDITE
LICENSING. SERVICES FOR ANY
PERSON OR BUSINESS THAT HAS
BEEN DISPLACED. BY DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE CENTER JONES WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. I'VE KNOWS NO KNOWN
NO KNOWN SUPPORT WITNESSES ON
THIS ITEM I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
HERE ONCE AGAIN WOULD BE
REMINDED THAT WE HAVE A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES- DALLAS BEGIN-
WITH THE THOSE IN ROOM TWO OH
FOUR OH WHO WISH JUST.
TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT. NOTHING IS CHANGED
IN ROOM TWO OH FOUR OO SO WE
WILL. IT'S EMPTY SO. WE'LL MOVE
ON NOW TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY BE A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. MODERATOR IF YOU
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT. WE WILL
BEGIN. SHOW OF SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
PHARAOH AT THIS TIME. AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEY'RE ALL AT
THAT TIME. THERE IS NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CAN YOU
CHECK ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD. YEAH
AS A REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEY'RE ALL AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN Q. AT THE MOMENT THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FALL
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR
MANY OPPOSITION. ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE CHAMBERS. SEEING THAT
WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWO OH FORO.
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION ON. WHAT ELEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT SEEING AND NONE-
MODERATOR CAN WE- CALL FOR
WITNESSES IN- OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE THE BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THE
MODERATOR I'M GONNA ASK YOU ONE
MORE TIME TO DO THAT JUST TO
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD. AS A
REMINDER TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
ONE THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE AND Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR UP
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK. TO SEE
IF ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WERE A
MOTION. CENTER WILK MOVES THE
BILL. I JUST WHAT CENTER JONES
I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT
YOUR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS ON
PAGE FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR MORALE. THAT
WAS A YES SIR AND- WHEN WE'RE
JUST TALKING IN ALSO VOTING
FROM YOUR SEATS COULD YOU PULL
DOWN THE MICROPHONE AND SPEAK
CLEARLY INTO THE MICROPHONE
MISTER JONES SAID. AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU GENERAL ACCEPTED
MOMENTS IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I APPRECIATE THE MOTIONS
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND
THERE IS NOBODY ON LIGHT SO- WE
HAVE A MOTION. THE BILL HAS
BEEN. MOVED AS AMENDED- TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIX SB ELEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOT. HI DON HI WILK.
WELCOME AYE ALLEN ALLEN HI
ANGELA. ACTUALLY I BRADFORD
BRADFORD I CHIANG CHIANG MAI
GALGIANI. GALGIANI AYE HILL
HILL HI WHAT'S SO. HUESO AYE
JONES JONES HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN
AYE PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER
I'D LAST FOURTEEN ZERO. WE GOT
THAT FOR ITS OUT FOURTEEN. ZERO
I DO WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY
ONCE AGAIN TO PULL DOWN THE
BIKE AND VOTE SORRY BUT THAT'S-
WE WANT TO GET THAT RECORDED-
APPROPRIATELY. SO THAT BILL IS
OUT OF FORTY NINE ZERO DOES WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
SEVEN BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
SENATOR YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR IN A- FIRST FOR
MISTER CHAIR TO YOU AND- YOUR
STAFF THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR DUE DILIGENCE ON THIS
BILL. WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
ALSO TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR ALL
OF THEIR WORK BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS MISTER CHAIR IS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO BE TO DEVELOP A
BROAD BASE FORMULA. THE FORMULA
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS. THOUSANDS OF THOSE
WHO ARE WITHIN THE WILD IN
URBAN INTERFACE. IN PROTECT AND
PRODUCE A STABLE RESIDENTIAL
INSURANCE MARKETS. CALIFORNIA
FACES A TERRIFYING NEW REALITY
IS. A GOOD SENATOR FROM NAPA IS
ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH. WHEN IT
COMES TO THE SIZE SCOPE AND
DEVASTATION OF WILDFIRES.
ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE AND
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED. THREE
POINT SIX TO FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. WHO
CURRENTLY LIVE WITHIN THE MOVIE
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO OPR. MASON
WILDFIRE RISK MODELS IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO MORE THAN ONE
MILLION HOMES WITHIN THE WILL
WE ARE IN A HIGH OR VERY HIGH
FIRE RISK AREA. INSURANCE
AFFORDABILITY AND AVAILABILITY
IS BECOMING INCREASINGLY
CHALLENGING. IN THAT BEING ABLE
TO EVEN ACCESS INSURANCE IS IN
THE COMING MORE CHALLENGING TO
OBTAIN FOR CALIFORNIANS LIVING
WITHIN THE WOULD BE.
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
HAVE BEEN NON RENEWED BETWEEN
200-015-2000 EIGHTEEN. RESIDENT
THE FACT BY FIRES WHICH TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND SEVENTEEN.
SIDE 10% INCREASE IN NON
RENEWALS RESULTING IN THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS LOSING THEIR
HOME INSURANCE. AND AS WE KNOW
WHEN HOMEOWNERS ARE UNABLE TO
SECURE INSURANCE THEY LOSE THE
VALUE WITHIN THEIR PROPERTY.
BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE WAS A
HUNDRED AND 77% INCREASE IN
FAIR PLAYING A ROLE MEANT. IN
THE STATE'S TEN HIGHEST RISK
COUNTY. BUT USUALLY THE FAIR
PLAN A IN AS WE ALL KNOW
USUALLY THE FAIR PLAN IS MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE AND OFFERS A
MINIMAL COVERAGE IN FAIR PLAN
RATES CONTINUE TO RISE. POLICY
HOLDERS ARE 20% AVERAGE RATE
HIKE LAST YEAR WITH SOME HIGHER
RISK PROPERTY SEEN AS MUCH AS A
SIXTY NINE POINT RATE HIKE.
THESE HOMEOWNERS IN HIGH FIRE
RISK YEARS ARE OFTEN THE SAME
RULE RESIDENTS. WHO ARE
ELIMINATE OR FIXED INCOMES.
HERE'S WHAT ELEVEN NINETY NINE
DOES MISTER CHAIR AND EXPEDITE
MY TESTIMONY. IT ESTABLISHES A
NEW COMMISSION ON HOME
HARDENING LED BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. WITH TO
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING
DEEPLY DRIVEN. IN
SCIENTIFICALLY SOUND BEST
PRACTICES FOR BOTH HOMEOWNERS
COMMUNITIES. TO REDUCE THE RISK
OF LOSS BOB MYERS. COMMISSION
ON HOME HARDENING WILL
ESTABLISH A TIERED SYSTEM FOR
STANDARDS FOR PRIVATE FIRE
PREVENTION. FOR VERY INDIVIDUAL
HOMES THE STANDARD TO INCLUDE A
VERY LEVELS OF HARDING
INCLUDING STANDARDS FOR FLYING
MEMBER RESISTANCE IN FOR
FLAMING HEAT RESISTANCE. TO
INCENTIVIZE HOMEOWNERS TO TAKE
THE STEPS BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
EXPENSIVE. AT THE THREE TIERS
DIRECTLY LINKED TO INSURANCE
DISCOUNTS FOR THE STRUCTURE
CERTIFICATION. THE COMMISSION
ON HOME HARDING WILL ALSO
DEVELOP A CERTIFICATION PROCESS
FOR COMMUNITIES AS A WHOLE. TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM THE
RISKS OF WILD. FOR COMMUNITIES
EARN SERVICE. INSURERS WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO DENY COVERAGE FOR A
RESIDENTS IN THAT COMMUNITY
BASED ON WHAT FAR RISK. NOW
THERE'S BEEN A HISTORY OF
SUCCESS ELSEWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY. FOR COMMISSIONS NOT
EXACTLY LIKE THIS BUT CERTAINLY
SIMILAR TO THIS. A SIMILAR
COMMISSION WAS CREATED BY THE
FLORIDA LEGISLATURE IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE IN RESPONSE. TO AN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF DEVELOPING
STANDARDS IN REVIEWING
HURRICANE RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY
INSURANCE RATES. THE CONGRESS
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS WITH
THE SPECIFIC DISCOUNTS LISTED
IN THE BILL AND THE REQUIREMENT
ENSURES RULE- BE UNABLE TO DENY
COVERAGE FOR RESIDENT. WHOSE
HARD THEIR HOME UNDER THE
STANDARDS AND I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND WHAT STAKEHOLDERS
CONCERNS ARE ABOUT INSURING
DISCOUNTS. THAT THEY REFLECT
THE ACTUAL EDUCTION AND FIRE
RISK IN THE DESIRE TO STILL
HAVE THE BILLY DENY COVERAGE.
AS A MEANS TO PREVENT INSURERS
FROM BEING OVER EXPOSED IN HIGH
RISK AREAS WE ALL WANT A
HEALTHY COMPETITIVE INSURANCE
MARKET NICHOLS ST. THAT WHERE
THERE IS ACCESS IN CHOICE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL REFLECT
OUR TEAM TO ENSURE THAT IF
YOU'RE RESIDENTS WILL BE. IN
THE TAKES STEPS INDIA AND BE
ABLE TO HARD YOUR HOME BASED ON
THE SCIENTIFIC STANDARDS
DEVELOPED BY THE COMMISSION.
YOUR TURN RATES WOULD REFLECT
YOUR INVEST. TO MAKE AS IN HOMA.
FINALLY. THIS AMONG. YEP SENATE
WHILE ACTION AND- DURING THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND TO COME TO SAY.
THANK YOU BEEN ON TO GET A WORK
WE CENTER RUBIO. CHAIR OF
INSURE ON THE SPECIFIC BILL. WE
AT THE CENTER OF YOUR EYE OR
CONTINUED OUR COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL.
KNOWING THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED
TO BE A TO WORK THROUGH THE
ISSUES MISTER CHAIR. I KNOW
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES.
THAT AT SOME WANT TO DISCUSS
TODAY. HELLO FOLKS KNOW THAT
THE DISCUSSIONS OF ALREADY
BEGUN. AND WILL CONTINUE WITH
SENATOR RUBIO IN THE WEEKS TO
COME AGAIN I WANT TO THANK HER.
FOR HER SINCERE IN. I KNOW. YOU
TO BE A PATCH IT ON THIS IS.
HERE AND THE WEEKS TO COME. I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY- TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL ISSUES. MICHAEL
MARTINEZ WHO SELECT DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT INSURANCE.
GETTING MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE. THE ABILITY TO
PRESENT AND I'M SORRY IT WAS SO
FRANKLY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR MCGUIRE NOW IT'S- BEGIN
WITH WITNESSES IN IN SUPPORT OF
THEIR ART AND NINE IN THAT THE
CHAMBERS WE'VE GOT TACTIC HELP
IF WE NEED IT HERE MOVING FOR
WE'RE GONNA MOVED TO ROOM TWO
OH FORO. ONCE AGAIN TO- FOR-
HAS NO WITNESSES BUT NOW WILL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
NIGHT I'D- SURE. ANY WITNESSES
SUPPORT PLEASE I'M YOU AND
SPEAK NOW. YES GOOD AFTERNOON.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE THAT WE DO
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS MEASURE BUT WE
DO APPRECIATE THE INTENT THE
BILL THERE ARE ELEMENTS OF THIS
MEASURE THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
COMMIT. BUT A- CHOOSE THE
CREATION OF THE STATE
INDEPENDENT COMMISSION.
COMPRISING OF STATE EXPERTS IN
THE FIELD OF INSURANCE FIRE
SAFETY BUILDING STANDARDS AND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS TO
DETERMINE BEST PRACTICES FOR
HOME HARDENING AND WHILE FOR
MEDICATION FOR IT WILL BE.
SECONDLY DEVELOPMENT OF
CLEARANCE AND STATEWIDE
WILDFIRE COMMUNITY HARDENING
STANDARDS. TO ENSURE ALL
COMMITTEES ARE GIVEN THE CHANCE
TO BE KNOWLEDGEABLE OF HOW TO
REDUCE THEIR WILD FIRE RISK
INSTRUCTOR MEET THEM IN ORDER
TO MAINTAIN THEIR INSURANCE.
AND THIRDLY A REQUIREMENT FOR
HARDING HOMES IN HARDIN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE CERTIFIED
TO RECEIVE HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
AND A MITIGATION DISCOUNT.
COMMISSIONER A LOT OF BELIEVES
HOMEOWNERS AND COMMUNITIES NEED
A CLEAR COMMITMENT BY INSURERS
TO WRITE INSURANCE COVERAGE
FROM FOR ME TO STANDARD. BUT
PROVIDING A STRONG INCENTIVE TO
REDUCE WALL VIRUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTINEZ.
PARKING NOW- MODERATOR FEW
POLICE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN NINETY NINE WE WILL
BEGIN. YES TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE I AT THIS TIME AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS COOPER HER WELL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA ALL MAKES THREE VERY
BRIEF POINTS ON THIS BILL WE DO
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON IT BUT A WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THURMOND WIRE AND HIS
STAFF FOR REACHING OUT TO US AT
THE STAKEHOLDER- WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND IS IN CONTRAST TO SOME
OF THE OTHER BILLS IN THIS
AREA. FIRST OF ALL WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THERE BE. A
HARD LOOK BEYOND WHAT'S ALREADY
OCCURRED ON HOME HARDENING THIS
COMMISSION THAT. AGAIN SOMEONE
INTO WHETHER APPROACH. WHAT
OTHER DESIGN AND OTHER STATES
WE HAVE NOTED TO THE AUTHOR AND
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT OPENING UP
PROPOSITION ONE OF THREE ALL
RIGHT NOT THAT WE DON'T THINK
THAT THERE IS MERIT. PARDON ME
BUT- ARE CONCERNED THAT ONCE
PROPOSITION ONE THREE IS OPENED
UP. THAT SOME OF THOSE WHO
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO SPELL- ARE
HAVE A WHOLE LAUNDRY LIST OF
CHANGES WHOLESALE CHANGES THAT
ARE FUNDAMENTALLY ANTI CONSUMER
AND ANTI POLICY HOLDER THAT
THEY'D LIKE TO. IMPOSE ON THE
BILL SO THAT CONCERT. FINALLY
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE
BIT OF A BOSNIAN OF THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE COMMISSION-
WE DO THINK THAT HISTORY HAS
SHOWN THAT YOU COMMISSION HAD
TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL WHEN THEY
ARE WATER. WE WANT TO HAVE TO
WORK OF A- AND A DANGEROUS
POLICY HOLDERS AND HOMEOWNERS
INVOLVED IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THAT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATE. THE CENTER AND
STAFF REACHING OUT AND THINK
YOU THEY WANT THE BILL TO LOOK
FOR WORK BUT WE HAVE NO
OFFICIAL POSITION AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. YOU MODERATE ARE
THERE ANY OTHER CALLS. WE HAVE
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS LOOK AT FOR
SOME HALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY I JUST WANT TO
OFFER OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
CENTER REQUIRES SB ELEVEN
NINETY NINE WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE HIS EFFORTS AND
YOUR EFFORTS- IN THE WILD
HIGHER ISSUES AT THE END HI
ISSUES ACROSS THE STATE AND
MORE ON THAT. LATER. SOME
THANKS FOR INTRODUCING THE
UNDER MY- THE HUMAN BIRKS AB MA
COULD YOU CHECK ONCE AGAIN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL SUPPORT WITNESSES ON
SB ELEVEN NINETY NINE. AND AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO IN THE
QUEUE AT THE MOMENT. HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WE WILL NOW FALL THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WE DO HAVE- WITNESS A IN IN
OPPOSITION. DANIELLE RITTER
FROM WORKING PROPERTY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION AND CENTER AND
TAYLOR FROM THE PERSONALLY
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'LL BE SPEAKING
IN ROOM. TWO OH FOUR OH YOU
DIVERTED SO YOU'RE HERE THE
CHAMBERS WELCOME. PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF CERTAIN
TAYLOR WITH THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION. AND ALSO
SPEAKING FOR THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES PADDOCK. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY AND THE
ADDITIONAL PRECAUTIONS THAT
EVERYONE IS TAKING HELP MAKE
OUR DEMOCRACY KEEPER CAN SAFELY
RESPECTFULLY WE MUST OPPOSE SB
ELEVEN NINETY NINE. APPRECIATE
CENTER REQUIRES A KNOWLEDGE
MEANT OF OUR CONCERNS. WELL WE
BELIEVE THE COMMISSION ON HOME
HARDENING IS A VALUABLE
COMPONENT OF ANY STRATEGY TO
REDUCE RISK OF LOSS RELATED TO
WILDFIRE. THIS BILL OVER
REACHES BY IMPOSING PREMIUM
DISCOUNTS BEFORE THE COMMISSION
IS EVEN STARTED HIS WORK. IN
ADDITION THE BILL FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE RECENT
INSURANCE AVAILABILITY ISSUES
IN HIGH FIRE THREAT AREAS ARE
DIRECTLY RELATED TO
UNSUSTAINABLY LOW STATEWIDE
AVERAGE PRICE LEVELS. WARNING
TO THE MOST RECENT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS DATA.
CALIFORNIA'S AVERAGE
HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE PREMIUM
ONE THOUSAND EIGHT DOLLARS IS
17% BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
AN ALMOST ONE HALF THE AVERAGE
PRICE IN HURRICANE STATES LIKE
LOUISIANA AND FLORIDA. EVEN
THOUGH TO SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
EXPENSIVE TO REBUILD THE HOME
OF THOSE LOWER COST GULF STATES.
NOW ANY FEASIBLE SOLUTION TO
THE INSURANCE AVAILABILITY
CHALLENGES AND HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS MUST RECOGNIZE THE
ECONOMIC REALITY OF LOW AVERAGE
RATES AND THE TWENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS OF LOSSES
INCURRED BY HOME INSURERS AS A
RESULT OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES.
WHICH AS NOTED BY MOODY'S
INVESTORS SERVICES DROVE
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
LOS RATIONS TO THE HIGHEST IN
THE NATION. NOW FURTHER THIS
BILL REQUIRES INSURERS TO
PROVIDE GUARANTEED COVERAGE
REGARDLESS OF RISK. IF AN
INSURER HAS INADEQUATE RATES
AND CANNOT MANAGE RISK THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY UNDERMINES THE
CONCEPT OF INSURANCE AND POSES
SERIOUS SOLVENCY ISSUES. NO
WELL WE ARE OPPOSED TO SB
ELEVEN NINETY NINE WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT WILD FIRE RISK
IN INSURANCE AVAILABILITY ARE
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED. WITH THAT IN MIND WE
BELIEVE TO MEASURES CURRENTLY
ADVANCING IN THE LEGISLATURE SB
TWO NINETY TWO BY SENATOR
RUBIO. AND AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
PROVIDING INNOVATIVE APPROACH
THAT BALANCES INSURER RISK AND
RATES. COMBINATION WITH A
SUBSTANTIVE EFFORT TO MITIGATE
WILDFIRE RISK AND LOSS AND IT'S
AN APPROACH ENSURES CAN SUPPORT
WITHOUT FEAR OF INSOLVENCY. NOW
THE COMMISSION ON HOME
HARDENING COULD BE A VALUABLE
PART OF THAT SOLUTION. BUT THE
INSURANCE PROVISION BILL ON
WORKABLE FOR US SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU IS THE
OTHER WITNESS- IN THE CHAMBERS
YES PLEASE PROCEED. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS DANNY WRITER ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION-
APCA APPRECIATES THE ABILITY TO
COMMENT ON SB ELEVEN NINETY
NINE AND WE'RE STRONG SUPPORTER
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
A SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO LIFE
AND PROPERTY THAT WILDFIRES
PRESENT. WERE ENCOURAGED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS CONTINUED
TO PRIORITIZE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION EFFORTS IN THIS
TRULY DIFFICULT TIME HOWEVER
WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS FROM PET MUST
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN NINETY NINE
DUE TO THE LIKELIHOOD THAT IT
WILL THROW STABILITY IN THE
INSURANCE MARKET. AND I. THE
AVAILABILITY OF INSURANCE I
THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE AND HIS
STAFF FOR WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
NOT DIALOGUE BUT IN ITS CURRENT
FORM I MUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE ON SB ELEVEN
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU MS
READER. ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION- WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWO OH FORO. SEEING THAT- WE
WILL MOVE ON- TWO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE AND IF IT
INDIVIDUALS PLEASE. YES AS A
REMINDER TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE
ARE AT THIS TIME AGAIN TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL ONE AND THEN
THERE I AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME A TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE-
WAITING TO- TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION. AND NOT AT THE
MOMENT BUT WE DO HAVE ONE.
THANK YOU AND WHEN YOU'RE READY
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR KERRY
MEMBERS- JOHN NOR WOULD ON
BEHALF OF LIBERTY MUTUAL
INSURANCE COMPANY OF THE
INDEPENDENT INSURANCE AGENTS
AND BROKERS OF CALIFORNIA- WE
HAVE SIMILAR CONCERNS. IN THE
CHURCH PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL-
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE CHAIR OF THE
CHARGE COMMITTEE ON A
RESOLUTION FORWARD THANK YOU
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER NORWOOD
COULD YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN JUST MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL THE
VISION WITNESSES. SURE AS A
REMINDER TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN TO OPPOSE THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE COMING IN AND TO BE
JUST A MOMENT. AND LOCAL TO
LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND I BACK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE ACTUALLY HAVE A AT
THE PORT IF AMENDED POSITION ON
THAT SO WE LIKE TO SEE THE AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY INCLUDED. ON
THE I KNOW THE BILL STATE THAT
THEY WILL BE- INCLUDED AS FAR
AS FEEDBACK THAT WE THINK IT'S
VITAL FOR THEM ACTUALLY TREATED
ON THE COMMISSION THAT IS
ENVISIONED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR EVEN ALSO THE LINE.
AND AGAIN TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
WE HAD NO ONE IN Q. AT THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR SO NOW THAT- I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS ANY MEMBER
WISHING US BODY. RUBIO CAN YOU
GUYS HEAR ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME
IT THANK YOU I'M GONNA TRY AND
SPEAK LOUDLY- WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR ALL FOR EVERYONE
THAT EXPRESS YOU THERE AT YOUR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT I KNOW
THAT WHILE FIRED THIS IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT'S IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
IN SOME OF THE MOST DEVASTATING
WILD IS WITHOUT A SIGNIFICANT
LOSS OF PROPERTY AND LIFE AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT REALLY
DESERVES OUR ATTENTION- AS-
CENTER CHOIR ALREADY STATED
VARY ISCUSS THE BELL AND I'VE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS AND I'M
REALLY THANKFUL THAT HE'S ONE
OF THE DOWN WITH A REALLY.
LANGUAGE BILLS TO COME. IN THAT.
AFFORDABILITY IN EXCESS WHICH
IS THE GOAL FOR ALL OF US TO
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS ARE WELL
PROTECTED AND SO AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND DOWN
JUSTICE STATE OUT PUBLICLY THAT
HE'S AGREED TO SIT DOWN WITH ME
THE LOOK OF IT NINETEEN A
PANDEMIC SIDE BILL IS NOT TO BE
HEARD IN THE INTEREST ANYWAY
WHERE IT WILL BE. LIKE MY CA
FOR BEING TOO. REALLY TAKE MY
AND SERIOUS AND SAID DOWN WITH
ME AND I'M ALL TO BE ON THE
ISSUE WITH HIM AS WELL. AND SO
WITH THAT TODAY WILL SUPPORT
THE BILL BUT AGAIN IT'S NOT.
FINAL FORM BILL I WILL CAN.
WITH I'D I'D ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
IS THERE A MOTION. WAS THAT
CENTER HILL SENATE MCGUIRE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. EXCUSE
ME. IT'S SORRY SAID AROUND AND
GET YOU THERE THANK YOU SO MUCH-MISTER I JUST WANTED TO- TO SAY
THAT- I WAS ABLE TO DISCUSS THE
NUMBER MY CONCERNS WITH THE
AUTHOR EARLIER TODAY A LOT OF
THEM AND DO WITH MAKING SURE
THERE'S FAIRNESS AND THAT ALL
SO. YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING.
OUT OF OUR WAY TO ENCOURAGE OUR
INCENTIVIZE FOLKS BUILDING- IT
CAN INCREASINGLY. DANGEROUS
FIRES OWNS. AND THAT'S THE KIND
OF AT THE HEART OF MY CONCERN
AND ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S NOT A- IN UNFAIRNESS
ENTERS A SUBSIDY. GOING FROM
FROM YOU KNOW WHO URBAN POLICY
HOLDERS TO FOLKS TO YOU KNOW
MAKE DECISIONS TO. DELIVER MORE
DANGEROUS AREAS AND SO ON WE
KNEW WE HAD A LONG CONVERSATION%
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE HIS
OPENNESS AND WILLINGNESS. HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION AND I'M
CERTAINLY PREPARED TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY. I WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE DISCUSSED.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN THE
OTHER DISCUSSION. SEE NOW WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR HILL
CENTER WHO ARE WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER KERR DO APPRECIATE THAT
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY AGAIN MISTER KERR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT THINK
IT IS AND RUBIO CENTER ALLEN-
IS WELL LOOK I THINK THAT ALL
IN HERE RIGHT HERE. ACCORDING
TO THE INSURANCE RIGHT NOW
TODAY. LOS LIVE IN HIGH. OF
FIRE AREAS ARE PAYING 50%
HIGHER THAN THE RATES. FOR
HOMES OUTSIDE OF THE WEEK SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. I THINK THE
OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
THIS IS THAT BETWEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN. THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE GRANTED
SIXTY FIVE RATE INCREASES. TO
THE MAJOR CARRIERS. ACROSS THE
STATE. AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN RECORD LOSSES
WE ALSO NEED TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE SUBROGATION. FROM
P. JEANNIE THAT ACTUALLY PAID
BACK SOME OF THOSE LOSSES. YOU
HAVE MY ABSOLUTE WORD MY
PROMISE THAT WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE. NOT JUST
WITH THE INDUSTRY. BUT ALSO
CONSUMER GROUPS TO BE A FIND
THAT SWEET FOR. THE GRATEFUL TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE. A IF YOU DO WE
YOUR TODAY UNDERSTAND WE KNOW
THERE'S STILL A LOT TO WORK OUT
ON THIS BILL. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SECURING COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE- THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR HILL.
MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE FOLLOWING
SEVEN SB LIVE. NINE MOTION IS
TO PASS. CAN YOU UP COMMITTEE
DODD I DODD AYE WILK. ALLEN HI
ALLEN I ANGELA ALL RIGHT BUT
SHOULD I BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
CHIANG JOHN NO GALGIANI
GALGIANI I FEEL. HILL AYE HUESO.
HUESO I JONES JON SNOW NIELSEN.
NO FOR NOW PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO. I WIENER.
THERE ARE NINE. AT TEN TO THREE.
THE BILL IS OUT- TEN EYES THREE
KNOWS WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT BY
CENTER. WHO WE WERE SENDING HIS
BILL REMOTELY. CENTER BORDERS
WELCOME YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN I
CONFIRM THAT YOU CAN HEAR ME.
LOUD AND CLEAR RIGHT ALL RIGHT
SB FIFTY SEVEN ALLOWS CORRECT
RELIEF BY RICK THE STATE
AGENCIES HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
COMPLY WITH STATUTES AND
REGULATIONS WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
AGENCIES TO ESTABLISH ALL FOR
THE READER OR WE WERE A COUPLE
PANEL. UNEXPECTED RECENT EVENTS.
BUSINESSES ARE IN PART OF OUR
STATE ACCORDING TO A REPORT
FROM THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
THE ECONOMY SMALL BUSINESSES
WITH LESS THAN ONE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES MAKE UP 97% OF ALL
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE AN
EMPLOYEE 30% OF THE WORK FOR.
AS PART OF CALIFORNIA YOUR READ
REALLY. ALL TO ME SMALL BIZ
AMBER ARE A DRY FORCE IN JOB
CREATION AND TAXED. DURING THE
PANDEMIC SMALL BUSINESSES A
WORKERS HAVE STEPPED UP STEPPED
UP TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
ESSENTIAL SERVICES IMPROVE. NOW
MORE THAN THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO TAKE ACTION TO PROVIDE
REGULATORY FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN
THE CENTRAL PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY. CURRENT LAW DOES.
AGENCIES MUCH DISCRETION WHEN
IMPOSING FINES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. WHILE THE INTENTION
OF THESE REGULATIONS IS NOT TO
START BUSINESSES THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN IMPOSED BY IMMOVABLE
PENALTIES IN LEAD TO BUSINESSES
CLOSING THEIR DOORS. SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN PROVIDES
AN AVENUE FOR REGULATORY RELIEF
AND IS BUILT. IN MEASURES TO
PROVIDE BAD ACTORS FROM TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS STATUTORY
CHANGE. UNDER THIS BILL A SMALL
BUSINESS VIOLATION CAN NOT
INVOLVED WILL FULL OR CRIMINAL
CONDUCT POSING IN THAT IT
HEALTH SAFETY OR ENVIRONMENTAL
THREATS. IN THE BUSINESS MUST
HAVE A LOW DEGREE OF
CULPABILITY. AGENCIES WOULD
HAVE TO JUST DECIDED NOT TO CAN
YOU WAIT OR REDUCE BASED ON A
NUMBER OF FACTORS FOR EXAMPLE
HOW THE BUSINESS COOPERATE
BRING INVESTIGATION. HOW THE
BUSINESS ENGAGE IN SUBSEQUENT
ACTION TO CORRECT THE
VIOLATIONS. OUR HISTORY OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS MEETING
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS AND THE
DEGREE TO WHICH THE PENALTY
WOULD IMPEDE THE SMALL BUSINESS
FROM CONTINUING TO OPERATE. SB
FOURTEEN SEVEN WILL FURTHER
ASSIST CALIFORNIANS ALREADY
TRYING IN UNCERTAIN TIMES. WE
MUST ALLOW THESE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS OF OUR COMMUNITY TO
YOU TO GROW IN STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY WITHOUT FACING COSTLY
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. BURGER THE
STATE'S COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON IT SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
CENTER PORCHES. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ANYONE WANTED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT CENTER BOARD
JUST SO I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
DAVID BUTLER FROM THE UNITED
CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK- WERE
LOOKING FOR HIM ON THE PHONE AS
WE SPEAK- MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE
HIM ON THE LINE. IF YOU ARE AN
ONLINE PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
FERAL OTHER RIGHT THEY DO NOT
SHOW THAT HE IS CONNECTED. OKAY
THANK YOU ANY IS NOT A- PLEASE
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE THE LINE
ONE MOMENT. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED. I CHAIRMAN
DODD- AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVE BUT
LEARN I'M TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF YOU CAN THE UNITED
CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK WHICH
IS A COALITION OF SEVEN LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA REPRESENTING
OVER FOUR THOUSAND. MEMBERS 80%
OF WHICH ARE SMALL BUSINESS
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES OR LESS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT WITH YOU TODAY. THE
EARN OF OUR MEMBERS
PARTICULARLY AT THE LEVEL OUR
TAXES FEES AND REGULATIONS AND
THE OVERALL CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
CLIMATE. OVER REGULATION IS ONE
OF THE DRIVING FACTORS BETWEEN
OUR MEMBERS PERCEPTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S POOR BUSINESS
CLIMATE AND MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES. I JUST DON'T HAVE
THE SAME OR- RESOURCES OF IT
ALL AS LARGE INDUSTRY
COUNTERPARTS. I'M AGAIN. EIGHT
EMPIRE AND FOURTEEN SEVEN THE
RESULT ROLE THAT SMALL BUT PLAY
ANY AND SEEKS TO REMOVE
ECONOMIC BARRIERS TO- SMALL
BUSINESS SUCCESS PARTICULARLY
AT THIS DIFFICULT TIME AND WITH
THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BUTLER ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWO OH FOUR OH THAT
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES IN TWO OR FOUR
OO. THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY BE A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF FORTY SB
FORTY FIFTY SEVEN WILL BEGIN.
AND IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN ANY WITNESSES TO PLEASE
PRESS THE LONDON THEY'RE ALL.
AND THERE ARE NO WITNESSES AT
THE MOMENT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATE WOULD YOU PROP ONE
MORE TIME SO WE MAKE SURE THAT
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO BE HEARD
DOESN'T GET LEFT OUT. SURE
ALMOST TO THE INDIVIDUALS TO
SHOW SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN TERREL.
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
TERREL. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WILL NOT FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. LET'S BE. ANYWHERE
THIS HERE. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO
OH FOUR OH WHO WISH TO. TESTIFY
OPPOSITE. FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
NO THERE IS NO OPPOSITION- IN
ROOM TWO OH FORO- WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OUR MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROP THE AND WAS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. YOUR
AWAY MANAGED WANTING TO OPPOSE
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN FERAL AND IF YOU ARE A
WITNESS. WISHING TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE AND KILL. THEM AND ASK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TO DO THAT ONE MORE TIME AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON. I AM LOCAL
TO THE INDIVIDUALS IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- DO WE HAVE
ANY OF OUR MEMBERS THAT HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CENTER CHIANG. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE BILL
AND I WANTED TO SEE IF I COULD
BE ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. SURE HE
WOULD. THAT WOULD THAT BE A
MOTION CENTER J. HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR CHIANG CENTER BURKE
GORGEOUS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. BOB I THESE ARE STRANGE
TIMES- BUT WITH THAT COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. OKAY FIT THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
CHIANG THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHT SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD
HI. DONNA HI WILK. WELCOME AYE
ALLEN. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA.
ACTUALLY THERE ARE BRADFORD ARE
BRADFORD AYE CHIANG. THANK GOD
YANNI GALGIANI AYE HILL. HILL
HI WHAT'S SO. WHAT'S ALL RIGHT
JONES. JONES I NIELSEN. NIELSEN
AYE PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO. REVIEW AYE WIENER.
WIENER ONLINE THAT'S FOURTEEN
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT FORTY
NINE ZERO KNOWS. I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS OR
PARTICIPATED THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO SUPPLY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL. RECORDS THANK YOU
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS AND STAFF HERE
TODAY FOR YOUR PATIENCE AD
COOPERATION THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. I IS GOOD YOU'RE
A JERK SHORTLY BUT I REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
STAFF AND ALL THE TECH TO
PEOPLE- FOR THE FANTASTIC WORK
ON GETTING THIS CAN. HEARING
DONE TODAY. PUT A DONE IT
WITHOUT YOU OBVIOUSLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEETING IS ADJOURNED.